[Music]
last month Nvidia released the RTX 590
and 80 well they sort of did some of you
maybe 10 of you were able to buy an RTX
5090 with uh let's say 80 of you getting
a 5080 so you know technically they were
released but then some of those 590s
have now melted so even less of you have
won but hey I'm sure there's more coming
anyway the disappointing 590 and 580
launch aside we now have the RTX 570 TI
to deal with a cutdown version of the 80
using the same GB 203 die uh the 5070 TI
is actually a far more interesting
product in my opinion as you are still
getting the same 16 GB vram buffer but
instead of costing $11,000 us which is a
criminal price tag for a 16 GB graphics
card in 2025 the MSRP is I'm going to
say alleged to be $750 US Today's
sponsor spot is brought to you by
thermal and their Tower 300 Micro Tower
case along with the th360 V2 Ultra ex
argb sync all-in-one liquid cooler the
tower 300 supports Mini ITX and microatx
motherboards with four expansion slots
the unique design is intended to support
the latest and greatest Hardware such as
the latest GeForce RTX 50 Series gpus
while still maintaining a compact
footprint and on top of that does so in
a configuration that best shows off all
of your glorious Hardware including your
motherboard graphics card and AO as for
the liquid cooler the th360 V2 Ultra ex
AO is equipped with three ct120 ex argb
sync fans and the pump housing includes
an LCD display which can be used to
monitor Hardware vitals or more serious
stuff like your favorite memes so for
more information please check the link
in the video
description now I know nidia's msrps
there about as accurate as my aim trying
to play fortnite after a few too many
drinks but I think the 5072 pricing will
be a little bit more realistic given
this product is likely to face some
competition from AMD but again it may
take quite a few weeks before we see
realistic pricing and I'm certainly not
guaranteeing this but if the 50 72i can
hit the $750 us MSRP then I think it
will almost certainly be a much better
buy than the RTX 580 and this is because
of will cost at least 25% less likely
quite a bit more than that but anyway at
least 25% less and it will pack just
177% fewer cores though they are clocked
6% lower there's a 25% reduction at L2
cach though because both models use a
256-bit wide memory bus the memory
bandwidth has only been reduced by 7%
this is due to the use of 28 GBS per
second gddr 7 memory opposed to 30 GBS
per second for the 580
so the performance downgrade here
shouldn't be all that significant and
again with both models featuring a 16 GB
vram buffer I think the $750 us price of
the 5070 TI is far more appropriate
essentially the 5070 TI is replacing the
4070 TI super coming in $50 cheaper and
it should offer a small performance
upgrade of course I have benchmarked
both models so we should go get into the
results before we do I should note that
for testing Nvidia has sent over the MSI
Ventus 3x version of the 570 ETI which
is slightly overclocked above spec but
please note for all of the testing I ran
the card at the reference clock speeds
as we do this for all models but for
those of you interested here is how the
Ventus 3x performs out of the box when
installed inside an ATX case in a 21°
room after an hour we saw a peak core
temperature of 64° and a memory
temperature of 7 26° at a fan speed of
1700 RPM this allowed the card to
average a core clock frequency of
2,780 mahz and consume 267 Watts so
overall a pretty cool running graphics
card also on hand is the gigabyte Arrow
OC model and under the same conditions
this card peaked at just
59° with a memory temperature of just
64° so quite a bit cooler than the
Ventus 3x but then the era OC is a much
larger graphics card which will no doubt
cost more we also saw an average core
clock frequency of 2,820 MHz at a fan
speed of 1250 RPM with a power drawer of
wat starting with Marvel Rivals we see
that the 5070 TI at 1440p is comparable
to the 480 super and therefore the
original 480 and this made it just 12%
slower than the 580 it's also 14% faster
than the 900 XT and 17% faster than the
4070 TI super so a reasonable
performance uplift over the model it's
replacing then at 4K it remained 12%
slower than the 580 and again delivered
480 super light performance which made
it around 20% faster than the 4070 TI
super and 7900
XT next up we have stalker 2 and here
the 570 TI is a lot less exciting and we
found the same issue with the 580 the
5070 TI was just a single frame faster
than the 4070 TI super at 1440p making
it a m 8% faster than the 7900 XT
interestingly it was also just 11%
slower than the
580 then at 4K it's just 5% faster than
the 47 super and 11% faster than the
7900 XT so pretty disappointing results
overall I'd say the new GeForce 50
Series have all been pretty
underwhelming in Counter Strike to at
1440p and the 50 70 TI is no exception
beating the 4070 TI super by a slim 1
12% margin making it 8% slower than the
7900 XT we do see much better results at
4K but even here the 5072 is just 10%
faster than the 470 TI super and a mere
5% faster than the 7900 XT so not the
most exciting
results next up we have God of War
Ragnarok and here the 5072 is 12% faster
than the 47 super at 1440p as well as
the 7900 XT that margin is extended to
177% at 4K so not quite 20% Which would
start to become I guess more meaningful
but it's still one of the better margins
that we've seen so far now I'm not
entirely sure why but for whatever
reason the GeForce 50 Series is very
underwhelming in Delta Force and as a
result the 57 is actually 4% slower than
the 47 ETI super and slightly slower
than the 79 100 XT increase in the
resolution to 4K does help but even so
the 57 is just 4% faster than the 470
super so in other words performance with
the new generation goes virtually
unchanged in this example which is
obviously very
disappointing the Star Wars Jo Survivor
results are extremely underwhelming here
it's just 9% faster than the 4070 TI
super and 11% faster than the 7900 XT as
usual the 4K data is a little more
favorable but even so here the 570 TI is
just 12% faster than the 4070 TI super a
plague toil requim has some of the more
favorable 57 TI data that we've seen so
far at 1440p it was 20% faster than the
47 TI super 24% faster than the 1700 XT
and just 11% slower than the RTX 580
oddly however it does slip a little bit
at 4K now leading the 470 super by a
177% margin and the 7900 XT by a 19%
margin though it did only Trail the 80
by a 133% margin cyberpunk 2077 has more
underwhelming 1440p data for us just a
9% uplift here when compared to the 4070
TI super or 10% faster than the 7900 XT
that said the 4K data is much more
impressive though probably not that
impressive overall as here the 5070 TI
is just 18% faster on average or 14%
faster than the 7900
XT the Dying Light 2 results are more on
the positive side of things let's say
here we're looking at a 19% Improvement
at 1440p which also made it 177% faster
than the 7900 XT and then at 4K the
margins extended to 25% over the 4072 I
super and 27% over the 1700 XT so it's a
real shame that we haven't seen more
margins like this the results in Dragon
Age the valard don't look too promising
here the 5072 TI was somehow slower than
the 4070 TI super trailing by 83% margin
at 1440p making it just 9% faster than
the 7900 XT that said when we jump up to
4K we see that it's able to just Edge
out the 4080 super coming in 133% slower
than the RTX 580 but 11% faster than the
4070 TI super the 5070 TI struggled to
improve upon the 4070 TI supers
performance in War Thunder at 1440p
delivering an additional 5% performance
with 378 frames per second that margin
grew to 10% at 4K as here we're looking
at 17900 XTX like performance while it
was just 10% slower than the RTX
580 SPID man remastered saw almost no
performance difference between the 57 TI
and 47 TI super at 1440p the new model
was a mere 1% faster and even at 4K
we're only seeing a 5% performance upli
for the 570 TI though that did make it
14% faster than the 7900 XT moving on to
Hogwarts Legacy here the 570 TI is 12%
faster than the 4070 TI super at
1440p though that did make it 15% slower
than the 7900 XT but if we increase the
resolution to 4K the 570 TI is now able
to match the 7900 XT along with the RTX
480 making it 14% faster than the 4070
TI super The Last of Us Part One
performance is pretty disappointing here
the 5070 TI is just 5% faster than the
4070 TI super at 1440p and 4% faster
than the 7900 XT then at 4K it ends up
beating both the 4078 super and 7900 XT
by a 12% margin so pretty much what
we've come to expect at this point
testing Star Wars Outlaws at 1440p only
saw a 5% uplift for the 5072 over the
4072 super though that did make it 19%
faster than the 7900 XT still even at 4K
we're looking at the same week gains
just a 6% uplift for an average of 36
FPS and last up we have Starfield here
the 55070 ti is just 9% faster than the
4070 TI super and 7900 XT at 1440p with
85 FPS on average so not amazing
performance really then at 4 okay things
change quite a bit but not to the
advantage of the 570 TI as here it's
just 4% faster than the 470 TI super
though it was 10% faster than the 7 to
900 XT but of course even that's a
highly disappointing
result okay so although we didn't look
at the 1080p data I do have the average
results so if you're interested you can
just pause the video here to take a
closer look now at 1440p the 570 TI was
just 7% faster than the 4070 TI super
and just 8% faster than the 7900 XT but
it was also 12% slower than the 580 so
relative to the 580 it looks pretty good
but then relative to the product it's
replacing it looks extremely
underwhelming as we often saw the 4K
data was more favorable and the margins
do grow in the 57 TI's favor though only
slightly as it's now 11% faster on
average than the 47 super it was also
14% faster than the 7900 XT and 133%
slower than the RTX 580 so again quite
good relative to the 580 but then weak
compared to the models it's meant to be
replacing now for measuring power
consumption I'm using the MSI RTX 5070
TI Ventus 3x OC which I've manually
downclocked to the official Nvidia spec
as we test all gpus at the reference
clock speeds however MSI might have
adjusted stuff like voltages which can
mess with efficiency and this is likely
why the 5070 CH seen to be consuming as
much power or in some instances more
power than the RTX 580 in our testing in
short the 5070 TI uses roughly the same
amount of power as the RTX 480 and 4070
TI super which generally makes it quite
a bit more efficient than the radon RX
XT okay time for a look at rate tracing
performance and we'll start with Metro
Exodus enhanced at 1440p where the 570
TI is 13% faster than the 470 TI super
so it would seem RT performance hasn't
been enhanced that said at 4K we are
seeing a 24% performance increase though
we did see gains of over 20% in the
raster testing though it was rare the
Allen wake 2 results though were very
disappointing here at 1440p the 570 TI
was a mere 2% faster than the 470 TI
super the margin though did open up a
little bit at 4K it's now 11% faster
which is a lot better but now we're
talking about 31 FPS with upscaling
enabled so not terribly usable in my
opinion cyberpunk 2077 has more
disappointing results for us extremely
disappointing in fact as the 5070 TI
manages to somehow end up slower than
the 4070 TI super at 1440p allbe it by a
single frame and even at 4K performance
is much the same so the 5072 is 11%
slower than the original RTX 480 given
it can only match the 4072 super so a
ter able set of results here in
cyberpunk the 5072 is CPU Limited at
1440p in Spider-Man remastered and as a
result it is able to match the RTX 580
making it just 8% faster than the 4070
TI super so increase in the resolution
does help and at 4K the 5072 is now 16%
faster than the 4072 super so not an
amazing result by any means but
certainly an improvement over what we're
seeing at 1440p
testing with Dying Light to at 1440p
only saw the 5072 app perform the 4072
super by a 133% margin which also meant
it was 133% slower than the RTX 580
jumping up to 4K slightly extended those
margins now the 570 TI is 177% faster
than the 470 TI super and 14% slower
than the RTX
580 then finally we have black myth
Wukong and at 1440 the 5070 TI was just
6% faster than the 4070 TI super with 57
FPS on average and remember we are using
quality dlss upscaling then at 4K you
get to enjoy a buttery smooth 31 FPS
with the very high quality Ray tracing
preset enabled along with quality dlss
upscaling which is 177% better than the
experience you'll get with the RTX 47 TI
super at 29 FPS so I guess you could say
it's an equally terrible
experience now again although we didn't
look at the individual 1080p results I
do have the average data so this is
1080p with quality upscaling and again
pause if you want to examine these
results now at 1440p with upscaling the
570 TI was just 6% faster on average
when compared to the 470 TI super so
extremely underwhelming results there
and this also meant it was 9% slower
than the RTX 480 and 14% slower than the
RTX
580 sadly the 4K data isn't amazing
either just 133% faster than the 47 CH
Super and 9% slower than the 480 super
with an average of just 51 FPS so the
5070 TI isn't really moving the needle
forward in terms of rad tracing
performance it's still a technology that
requires huge investment to really enjoy
fully okay so I have a number of pricing
breakdowns for you and we'll start with
the official MS RP data which at least
on nvidia's side of the fence has been
horribly unreliable as of late this is a
big problem because if the rx570 was to
sell and really be readily available at
the $750 us MSRP it would be a good Buy
in today's market offering the same
level of value as the 7800 XT with
drastically better RT performance and of
course dlss support it would also be a
16% Improvement in cost per frame when
compared to the 4072 I super so not
amazing for a nextg product but if
you're in the market and were looking at
spending around $800 us on a graphics
card the 507 tii would be really
exciting that said it would be if it
were $750 us and it seems unlikely that
you're going to be able to snag one for
that price but let's stick with Enid's
$750 us narrative for now and see how
that compares to the best GPU pricing of
mid 2024 as you can see the 5070 TI
still Stacks up really well beating the
value of the 7900 XT essentially wiping
that product out it's also 14% better
value than the 4070 TI super so pretty
good certainly not amazing after 12
months but it is a step forward and
steps forward haven't been easy to come
by in the GPU market now although I'm
sure there will be $750 us listings for
the rtx550 70 TI stock levels are
expected to be almost non-existent for
those models rather most models will be
priced well over the $750 us MSRP and in
fact the typical asking price is
expected to be more like $900 us so a
similar situation to what we see with
the RTX 580 which is meant to cost
$1,000 but really costs at least
$1,200 and the 590 which is meant to be
$2,000 us but is really more like
$25,000 us so if we adjust the RTX 580
to $1,200 and the new 570 TI to $900 us
we see that the 5070 TI is offering the
same value as the 4070 ti supera so no
improvement in cost per frame and this
is more what we've come to expect from
Nvidia still when compared to the 7900
XT the 57 eiti still looks great here
because AMD screwed up the release
pricing of that product so badly it
beggar belief but what this data tells
us is if the RTX 570 TI sells for $900
us or more it's a complete flop you'd
have been considerably better off buying
an RTX 40 72i super a year ago or an RTX
4072 I 2 years ago because having an
additional 2 years of enjoyment out of
your $800 us purchase adds considerably
more value even if 2 years later the
same investment lands you 20% additional
performance though the only problem with
the 4070 TI is that it is a very
expensive 12 GB graphics card so I think
the 4070 TI super is probably the better
option of well the three potential
options here now the situation over in
Australia is even worse somehow and this
data is based on current so real retail
pricing this means the 1700 XT Stacks up
better though not much better and
certainly not well enough to recommend
it given it only improves the cost per
frame by 6% when compared to the 4070 TI
super now the 570 TI is meant to have a
recommended retail price or RP of
$159 Australian dollar and again while
some base models will be listed at that
price stock is going to be extremely
limited and some retailers won't even
have those models at all rather the
cheapest model you're likely to be to
get your hands on will cost 8% more at
1,630 Australian
though again most models will cost even
more than that but what this means is
here in Australia the cheapest RTX 570
TI are coming in at an 11% increase in
cost per frame over existing 4070 TI
super stock so 23% more money for 11%
more performance so yeah that's pretty
crap even at
1,59 Australian dollar it sucks in my
opinion a direct conversion from $750 us
to Australian dollar equals
$1,180 add in some tax and you just shy
of
$1,300 so the current asking price of
the 40 72i super but for some reason
another $200 Australian dollar has been
tacked on but really it's going to be
even more than that so there you have it
if sold at the $750 us MSRP the 5070 TI
would be a reasonable buy at least in
the current market but opinions aside
for a second let's go over some of the
facts when compared to the 4070 TI super
at 4K the 5070 TI is on average 11%
faster with margins seen as high as 24%
in our testing though margins of 20% or
larger were quite rare as that 11%
average would suggest the rate tracing
performance was much the same 133%
faster on average with margins of up to
24% so typically speaking the 57 TI is
going to end up less than 15% faster
than than the 4072 I super now for those
of you still using an older GPU such as
the RTX 370 for example the 5070 TI is
offering on average 103% grader
performance at 1440p and
155% grader performance at 4K so a
massive upgrade there though the MSRP
has increased by 50% or rather 22% if we
adjust for inflation you're also getting
twice as much vram which is a big one
given the RTX 370's 8 GB buffer is
regularly run over these days of course
we're talking about the $750 us MSRP
which we know at least for the release
isn't really a thing and probably won't
be for at least a few months so it's
going to be really interesting to see if
AMD is able to capitalize on this and
crush the 5070 series out of existence I
certainly wouldn't bet on it especially
given amd's track record but this is the
best opportunity they've had to strike
in years there's really not much more to
say about the 507 tii at $750 us it' be
a decent deal certainly not amazing not
super exciting but you know a good deal
all the same but at over $800 us it's
extremely disappointing and a regretful
purchase for those of you who didn't
just go and snap up a 407 chi super like
a year ago for now we're going to have
to wait and see where pricing ends up
probably in a few months time and of
course what AMD ultimately ends up
firing back with we will see that uh
much sooner so with that I'm going to
end this review of the RTX 5070 TI if
you enjoyed it give it a like let me
know what you think about the 5070 TI
and of course we do have the 5070 coming
up soon as well so make sure you
subscribe for that uh we also have the
join button patreon if you want to
become a harbor unbox member gives you
access to our exclusive Discord server
monthly live streams Q&A stuff and
behind the scenes content so check that
out if you're interested but if not
that's perfectly fine and I would like
to thank you for watching this video I'm
your host Steve see you next time
[Music]